yeah I'm in tulip I'm too orange
here we go here we are you okay hi guys
my name is Grace le we didn't know now
you know your life is different now I'm
here with mamrie art and joseline youth
and today we are doing a very fun video
because we're so fun reason Wendy's
loves to work with us something tells me
they like a redhead yes sir that's what
it is they have a brand new series of
summer salads that they're rolling out
you guys can tell we are imperfect human
beings why I don't have an elite shower
today but the good thing is though we're
imperfect we can find solace in these
perfect delicious fresh Wendy summer
salad we got a mango strawberry chicken
and feta salad - without chicken or feta
because I'm a vegan when I got right I
have a fresh mozzarella salad with
chicken Wow and I got that salad with
the mango and the strawberry with
chicken and feta and sunflower seeds
well love it so the drivers point home
that we are in perfect which I'm sure
you guys know already we're going to
play a game called fork it over
it's like we never have I ever but if we
have done the thing that is suggested in
the question we have to eat a bite of
salad something tells me I'm going to be
full after this mine in another now
luckily Wendy's dropped off 40 - okay
you may have submitted to us on Twitter
so never have I ever typed questions and
we're going through them right now in
this rousing game of four nothing was
ready to get it right on that um
perfectly grabbed the wrong one never
have I ever accidentally leaked a
friend's phone number I was live
streaming with you and I started to
prank call Harley Morenstein Jeff and I
went like this to show everyone who was
watching that I was actually calling him
and
and this number papa unluckily that was
five years ago so video quality was so
bad and you want to make up a better
number
Oh Mary thank God you never leave my
phone number because getting a new phone
is expensive you know it's not expensive
these new salads from Wendy's very
affordable never have I ever eaten an
entire box of pasta in one sitting
dried or cooked what okay this one's
pretty users never ever laughter in
serious moments oh I believe we all have
yes the good old church laughs everybody
needs to do that
never have I ever been on a boyband
themed cruise I don't even something to
be ashamed of at all knowing I think
that adds here for French to decide my
cheer oh and ain't care about it
perfectly my all coming Bob
I never have I ever had a crush on a
friend's parent excuse me never have I
ever fallen asleep on a bus or train and
not gotten off at my stop and ended up
somewhere else oh I was like no way and
then I remembered waking up in Coney
Island I'm sorry but sometimes the
subway is the worst capsule of crazy of
all time and sometimes it's like being
rocks to sleep yeah I knew when you
waited like two hours to get the subway
oh I know I see also to take it to an
extreme level yes falling asleep at my
gate at the airport and woken up hours
later what a different flight was
boarding at my gate got in line for that
play and almost like your plate left two
hours ago and I fell asleep ten feet
from the entrance when of mixed up you
know what else is mixed up on the daily
these salads from Wendy's so fresh so
quality but seriously they're really
precious never have I ever farted and
woke myself up you guys how about that
someone you scream grab that was ugly
vermin we're going to talk about this
one can we justify idli eat nothing
might live in that quantum noise oh did
you and a friend man that I've murdered
of course well nobody's perfect
I'm gonna catch that on an old Greece
video yeah - find Ava comment in the
comments below if you can find the video
which we talked about that never might
work all to teach your mom or dad I've
actually never done that you know I
haven't done that but I have definitely
been on a call up like a customer
service rep for something and then my
leg thank you so much okay love you
never have I ever gone skinny-dipping
I don't like once a week in my hot tub
of my morning coffee well and if you
haven't skinny dips what do you Dallas
let him out to play never have I ever
pretended to like someone that I don't
like sweetheart never have I ever used
my pet as bait to get someone's
attention
[Music]
never I never cut my own men yeah I mean
I had I had a delicious salad I might
have been restrained from cutting my own
bags too much sugar level oh yeah hmm I
have not either right how they look
right now never ever stop the fans
social media account oh yeah yeah I've
looked at an account and gotten so deep
into the archives and is that like I was
I was touching it like I was doing
surgery so I wouldn't accidentally like
that swallowed it you know what else is
quality news salads I made with fresh
ingredients all of us feel much better
about ourselves and all our
imperfections because it's our comforted
us it much cheaper than therapy
by the way she was in therapy thank you
guys so much for watching this video
hope you enjoyed it I hope you learned a
lot about us and how imperfect we are
and how perfect Wendy's salads are make
sure you guys go subscribe the jobs of
the channel and two main reach and
follow them on all their social media
because they're hilarious human beings
in all of their imperfections leave a
comment down below what if these never
have I ever time you guys done what's
been
your most embarrassing moment or where
these salads looks the best to you I
would love to know do three a thumbs up
and subscribe to this YouTube channel I
make videos Monday Wednesday and Friday
sometimes on different days than that
you can see other than that I don't know
I don't know how that happened
[Music]